hello you i'm so glad you're here  welcome to the town of clover grove  hello jack hello jack where one act of  kindness the prize can grow and grow to  help you finish your big game and start  a chain of many more come on we can play  the game with cooper  welcome to the hummingbird cafe try a  little act of kindness i've never been  on a bus before i'm imagining  hello bob show a stranger some  politeness want to sit next to me we can  be bus practice  that looks so great you know thanks and  thank you crams oh thank you oh you got  it hugo  kindness starts  with a simple hello hello you hello jack  the kindness show exclusively streaming  on apple tv plus